california governor gavin newsom waging
and i mean war a total war
on red states the left-wing leader
trying to make the case that what
america really needs right now is more
of his state's failed progressive
policies
newsom has been bashing republican-led
states for weeks and is even running ads
in florida encouraging people to move to
california
freedom it's under attack in your state
republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors i urge all of you
living in florida to join the fight or
join us in california but we still
believe in freedom freedom of speech
freedom to choose freedom from hate and
the freedom to love don't let them take
your freedom
newsome appears to have an eye on 2024
and this new poll could help him decide
it has been performing better than
kamala harris in hypothetical 2824
matchups judge i heard you groan oh my
god at one point no i said gosh gosh
excuse me i said oh my gosh what were
you referring to well he says there's
freedom there in california i was in
california during covid it was locked
down it was depressing you couldn't go
anywhere you couldn't do anything and i
was in florida like a week later it was
like nobody knew what was going on and
then you compare the mortalities and the
deaths between florida and this guy
should be embarrassed he should be
embarrassed with that ad he's
good-looking he's cute some people vote
for him because of that but at the same
time i mean why are you [ __ ] a fight
why are you picking a fight with
desantis i mean you can't compare
yourself to desantis and the numbers he
wants he wants people floridians to join
the fight they're leaving california in
droves to go to florida is he stupid and
now florida is one of the main areas
people want to move to california is
like down at the bottom of the list and
i rest my case
that case closed would you like to
respond
i think he's very cute too
[Laughter]
it was an interesting target i
understand that he wants to run in 2024
at least is mulling it 2028
get on the national stage but picking
florida is a strange choice i thought i
would think something more regionally
somewhere where you could say hey this
isn't that far away you have really
restrictive policies here you can come
here for you know our beautiful more
restrictive policies
no i i know that not everyone agrees
with me on this but there are a lot of
people who don't want to live in states
where abortion has been banned that
it's true all right
okay
it's just objectively true
but gavin newsom jb pritzker we already
talked about him a bit jared polis from
colorado
these are people who are in executive
positions of power when you think about
the presidency it's a management job
right and people are going to be looking
at people who have been managers so
mayors governors etc so in that sense it
it makes sense to me and that they're
making this very aggressive case for
liberal policies for the successes that
they've seen at home because if you're
putting that against what people feel
about what's going on with joe biden
right now
it's a it's a smart move to be making
people say oh biden isn't really out
there he's not advocating for anything
he's not defending us and our way of
like the liberal world order as you were
as as you would um so i think that's
what
is going on does it come across as a
little clumsy
the way he kind of rolled out this
campaign against florida
yeah yeah i i started cracking up when i
saw the actual ad campaign taking on ron
desantis claiming freedom is under
attack
i mean on the same day where literally
it's been revealed now that the red
states are winning the post-economic
recovery from the pandemic after being
criticized for staying open they were
they were tax havens for people who
wanted to flee these high tax states
florida got all the people
the number one state they left was
california so i don't even know how what
he's working off of i mean so these red
states by the way are thriving in the
post pandemic economic recovery and that
is going to win a lot of votes come
midterm elections watch it
greg do you understand this move he's
making
i don't know and do you think he's
handsome oh very handsome in fact uh
gavin's ascent says everything unfair
about life what trump's race engender
looks all the time if you're handsome 90
if you're handsome you keep your nose
clean you can get anything you want in
life if he looked like gerald nadler we
wouldn't be having this conversation
california but he keeps getting elected
well california is a mess but he isn't
you know he's delicious
you know and so he he he's the only only
reason why he's taken seriously as a
candidate it's because he's got the
hairline but you know just think about
this sit back all you fivers all you
fivers have been watching this show for
a decade imagine if he gets the
nomination and runs against trump
imagine
imagine
imagine how crazy that's gonna it's
gonna be crazy hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else